d'ici 2024 la colline d'elancourt va
changer d'apparence le lieu accueillera
les épreuves de vtt pour les jeux
olympiques
un projet ambitieux pour cet espace
aujourd'hui peu utilisé à l'airé
couverte essentiellement d'arbres qui
ont poussé tout seul et d'une végétation
à la fois luxuriante mais également
sauvage on a un certain derrière de
plantes invasives un hématome à sauvage
qui se trouve plus au fil des années par
le fait que les tétons sont passés des
gens en vélo et parfois malheureusement
des gens également en moto en quad sont
pas les bienvenues mais qui utilise
cette colline et elle est aujourd'hui
essentiel bourg ouvertes simplement la
probable les différentes phases du
projet ont été annoncés lors d'une
réunion publique en ligne mercredi 7
juillet pendant la compétition tente
tribunes et gradins accueilleront les
équipes sportives technique et pour
l'après 2024 des aménagements sont
prévus fait des espaces de détente et de
promenade pour les familles un dieu
ouvert et accessible pour les pour les
piétons pour les familles pour les
parents les enfants à l'ensemble des
usagers possible renforcer la pratique
de la course à pied en paiement de des
circuits de détente et de promenade
développer une offre de vtt complète et
adaptée à tous à conserver la piste vtt
olympique avec un rayonnement sportif
international qui va nous permettre de
réorganiser par la suite d'éventuels
événements internationaux
autre point important la préservation de
l'environnement naturel de la colline on
va complètement transformer cette
colline la rendre durable point de vue
de l'environnement puisque les a plantés
sur les arbres bénéfique avec ips étudié
pour vivre à cet endroit là qu coexister
dans les milieux et également qu'ils
seraient étudiées pour qu' un certain
nombre d'espèces qui vivent aujourd'hui
ça collait me voir qui ont disparu
puisque venir y revivre une concertation
est prévue du 20 septembre 20 octobre
2021 objectif informer le public et
recueillir les avis sur les
caractéristiques du projet